hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play lost the light I think it's
called yeah that's it
lost Lloyd for some reason share here Oh
your normal back to normal I'm kinda
hesitant to take you with me are you
sure you're okay sure you're okay yeah
oh it's blocked off now okay that's good
I didn't want to go that way anyway huh
no completely blocked off okay that's
okay that's okay that's okay that's okay
where'd that fire come from huh I don't
remember that diet look huh
Oh uh-huh
all right I'm tougher than this come on
what have you got nothing this should be
downstairs lost their lights okay Daniel
is that a guy on the shadow hey hello
can you hear me what is that a guy on
the shadow what the hell does that mean
oh no no no water not water not water ah
damn you damn you
[Music]
go over there I thought I heard two of
them but apparently it's just the one oh
there is one in there wait no what what
the hell is that
it's a tinderbox just bouncing up and
down
let me holy crap okay what's in here
what's in here what's in here is there
anything in here ladder
what's a ladder go all on top of the
things okay oh hello found an item
needle oh okay
it's like it was about it in here I
don't know no no no not today
oh okay I'm just going it's good
screw you okay please open I don't even
I can't even see Oh laudanum barely
conscious from one hit how do I get this
how how oh the needle the needle
oh it's on the other side oh go away go
away buddy go away okay box over there
maybe Beckett huh give me the box
give me the box give me the box
all right huh
oh I already did open it okay and then
close it close it close it okay
yes close okay I'll shoot three ah
no no no please I don't have any dead
flesh what do you want me to cut off my
arm okay I got through here come on
Jemma come on come on come on I got you
I got you
I gotcha hmm hmm aha
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah oh what the hell
is that down there
I see something
haha no God okay
from David from David right he made it
so far I capitalized so is it a puzzle
can you do me a favor can you please
find my two friends they were looking
for the acid they did not they did find
it and brought it back to the lab
unfortunately they forgot the forgot the
jar could you go and look for
okay
okay okay
damnit there seems to be a padlock in
extremely good condition
keeping this door closed it looks new
you define the padlock key chairs
this environment does look different
okay
so far so terrible
I'm okay I'm tough on the toughs there
ever is was his was
okay we're all okay everything is fine
there is no text in the loading screens
it's just the same the image and the
loadings is taking a bit longer than I
remember but I guess it's okay no big
deal no big deal okay give a good time
to relax try to come home this place
feels strange
I do like that they've done a bit of
different design
okay yeah I wasn't going crazy those
lights are shifting anything under the
stairs what the hell is that
ah no no oh no no no aah
Barney Nene dead bunny can see okay okay
we're okay
smashed chair chair dot died here man
the atmosphere it's custom stories
intense a mallet sledgehammer
oh yeah oh hell yeah like a slope okay
there's some oil I got you in the land
of birth work huh
Oh Oh they didn't give off any light at
all okay
whoa all right this is why it took so
long to load why do I suddenly feel
shorter
I'm not crouching what the hell how wait
out suddenly I'm like tiny huh Wow
okay I don't have enough oil to really
rock get whatever I don't really have
enough oil to LA this morning there's
more actually giving me more okay
where the hell am I going yeah
everything got gigantic seriously how do
they do this
do they just scale everything up or did
they actually do something to me to make
me moment ah
[Music]
wow that door at least is relatively
normal size I don't have a hammer I lost
my sledgehammer who's that
come on don't don't face me bro come on
anybody anybody
this is sack of potatoes tinderbox
nothing else a jar why is the light
shining on this char
[Music]
shut up creepy music whispering
seriously a sense of scale in that room
just threw me off ah more oil oh yes oh
oh it's even have oil leftover perfect
the workers proved to be working very
efficient lead but some of them are
getting nightmares about the safe it's
getting them distracted okay
something about this safe again whatever
what the hell like upside down maybe
we'll drop something in my opening come
on last one not buried in the dirt okay
just came in here for the oil then
getting out here this is how a horror
game should be by the left a lot of
buildup not so many monsters a lot of
tension hello hello anybody here no more
tension no monsters no where are you
where do I go what do we do dad flash
could act in the destruction how is that
helpful for me how is that helpful it's
not not helpful not helpful at all oh
let's go all this wrong let's go okay I
still get full oil okay
alright alright just go let's go let's
go yeah let's go let's go try one of
these other doors someone just come on
come on oh it's the same deal oh except
I can't go down here ah I gotta go to
the other way okay actually that's all
the time I got for this episode thank
you guys so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next part
bye bye